to estimate the amount of force required
to blow up such a huge whale British
explosives expert Terry Thompson reviews
the footage of the bloody aftermath this
incredible event involved a rupturing of
the sperm whale's abdomen which caused
material from the sperm whale to be
projected quite a large distance for
instance here you might just be able to
make out a mass of material just to
Jason next to this car here that car is
about 30 metres from the sperm whale so
for that to have been projected 30
metres indicates to me just how volatile
and event this was mayest nation of this
would be it would be the equivalent to
between 2 to 5 pounds of TNT equivalent
explosives would have caused similar
damage to test his theory Thompson is
using 4 pounds of dynamite to simulate a
blast we are going to detonate in the
middle of a huge mound of peat it will
produce a tamping effect on the
explosive the peat beds are
approximately the same size and weight
of the body parts that were thrown
across the street
if the pee bags are throwing us into the
distance and some remain intact then the
experiment will have been successful we
can see from here there's still quite a
few full bags lying around I can see a
kidney there it's quite easy to imagine
that that's your part of the world
intestine
similarly with all these other bags
[Music]
Thompson's estimation looks accurate the
heavy peat bags have thrown a similar
distance to the where's Gus
I think that says near a representation
of what took place in Taiwan is look at
a possible opportunity the blasts
required four pounds of dynamite the
equivalent of 30 hand grenades if
anybody had been unlucky enough to be
standing immediately adjacent to the
vehicle when that happened they would
have suffered quite serious injury
perhaps even death
but how can a mammal contains such a
huge amount of potentially lethal energy